all right
hey you're really gonna love this
i feel like i'm not every time you
confidently say that i end up not loving
it your girlfriend laura loomer
laura loomer is that what she did do you
even know what she did you don't even
know what she did
mike hasn't seen this on my left uh
i'm gonna go with something stupid for
uh 200
yeah show me something stupid
[Applause]
so laura loomer confronts jack dorsey at
bitcoin 2021 conference something stupid
was the number two answer on the board
loomerd this is from her youtube page by
the way
in miami
fighter on a mission to protect
free speech and get way too much plastic
surgery
[Music]
i i i i don't think her water mark is is
big enough i don't think she has enough
of a watermark on her video
oh my god that's jesus it's the whole
screen
oh my god shouldn't anybody steal any of
this focus on making bitcoin
the native currency for for the internet
so okay i'm gonna warn you right now
you're gonna cringe really hard this is
a warning to everybody
no because it's loomer and we're gonna
end up cringing from this just a warning
everybody listening
uh it's about to get real cringy up in
here
all right so just be ready that's right
she came here to get plastic surgery and
make everybody cringe
and she's all out of plastic surgeons
okay i'm gonna do it this is really
rough i it's just
she's your friend say that this is a
currency for everyone in the world
no she's your friend whatever world
when you are the king of censorship
bitcoin is about decentralization
and you have no right to be here today
and it's gonna be a lot of booing isn't
it it's about to start isn't it
oh god you know what it is it's like
you know what laura loomer is a
culturally
like she's like the culture war
equivalent
of like an angry black woman where
okay sure let's say they got your order
wrong right
you could send an angry black woman in
to deal with the situation right
but is it the best choice or are there
better
more tactful ways to go about getting
what you want
in life and it's like sending
laura loomer is the person you send in
and now all diplomatic possibilities are
done it's just now everyone looks like
an [ __ ]
somebody saying she's not wrong nobody's
saying she's wrong here's the thing
your message can be on point and deliver
it
in the worst way no one's even arguing
what she's saying is incorrect
because all the articles now are going
to be uh lord loomers to storms of stage
again
yeah like we get mad at censorship all
the time but i don't show up to like
some youtube thing and just start
screaming
with chickens and this doesn't get
results no one's going to be unbanned
because of what lord lumer did
what desantis did is helping get people
unbanned yeah not this
why is she wearing a trucker hat because
she's just
she asked in kutcher's in the early
2000's she's just like you or me man
she's just cool is that a von dutch hack
dutch is she rocking a von duck dickies
[Music]
wearing a car hard hoodie stop
stop
oh [ __ ]
okay here we go
do you know why this isn't working
because they're not even kicking her out
and jack [ __ ] peyote dorsey
is saying we'll get to that don't worry
we'll actually we'll get to that
what's going on where am i
hey aren't you that chick that
handcuffed yourself to our headquarters
hey listen if i owe you money for
something man just talk to
i mean the indian girl so handle it
[Applause]
and there you go
[Applause]
she looks like she looks like she's 50
now
that's not true most of her parts are
new but that's why
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right get him laura there it is
that's right add chinese to it
chinese technical fascists
you're right since she's 28 really
that is a rough 28 she really does look
like wholesome bread left out in the
rain
too much dude too much work man you get
too much work done and you end up
looking either 60 or trans
we're both if you're the health director
assistant health director of the country
oh there's more though
[Music]
you see the security guards hitting on
her
oh this is the miami convention center
right yeah it looks like it i'm a
reporter with bitcoin magazine i just
wish there was a way to know if this
video came from loomer
i think dude don't quote me on it but
i'm pretty sure watermark is about i'm
pretty sure i'm not 100
positive this is giving me like [ __ ]
i don't know man it's giving me epilepsy
oh my god the lip injections too like
dude
from when from when i first met her
until now wow man
when she had the first nose job it was
fine
it was fine stop there it was like okay
you're like
because look i'm gonna say this and this
is gonna be taken
kind of mean right but like you can get
all this work done and stuff right but
think of it like like like a video game
where like if you pick a certain race or
a certain
character to start you're going to have
a certain base stats right
so you can you can only get
so much work like you can only be so
pretty
it's you're right like you know what i
mean i can only be
so pretty if i get some work done royce
can only be his level of so pretty
you can only be your level of perfect
perfection and i'm not saying you should
just saying that if you wanted to get
some little touch-ups
but if you start getting a little too
carried away and chiseling a little way
too much bone and cartilage
you start looking don't get that back
you can't get that yeah you just
look i'm all for like look when you get
older and [ __ ] i'll be all about trt in
about five years
probably you know maybe you get a little
botox a little bit
you know some people get a little
touch-up and if you get one or two
touch-ups along the way
it'll help you look good but when you
just start going all right guys
start getting in there and really
getting into the foundation
it never turns out good you can only go
so far with it
if you're super hot already naturally
and then you get a little bit of work
you could be mega hot
but if you're super hot as we've seen in
hollywood
you get too much work and now you're a
[ __ ] monster she's she's approaching
monster status
someone called her dick tracy villain
she said the cheeks done too and the
chin i think she had her chin done
someone said she modded the skyrim
character editor
[Laughter]
people are saying do you want to play a
game she looks like the saw doll
dude i think she's got a chin gun too
i'm not kidding
uh we did some before and afters in the
show oh is it is it is she hot
oh my god okay so let's
let's do the before first obviously that
would be the right order
royce uh there's the before
that's classic loomer right that's not
judy gold
are you sure it's in the young judy gold
yes
that's the before and here's the after
picture here it is okay that's not
no that's the
[Music]
even this right here even this is post
nose job
i think there you go okay that's
that's
even that's not his she's had work done
since this yes absolutely that's what
i'm saying this is the middle of the
road
this was where it was like okay okay now
stop
she just kept going man
ask her outside outside the venue right
this way
[Music]
he's on stage with a human rights
activist right now jack dorsey is
committing millions of human rights
violations by interviewing an election
millions millions of human rights
violations
in my election
laura look you didn't lose because of
jack dorsey okay
after confronting jack dorsey about his
hypocrisy regarding free speech
censorship and decentralization laura
lumero is removed by security from the
bitcoin code that's
pretty rebellious dude wow
these is this it now is this like lake
worth huh
how long have we been doing this [ __ ]
uh how long have we been doing this
[ __ ]
these stunts since we at least since
we've started this show
oh my god god at least since we started
the show she's been doing these uh these
stuff i like words
that's just where her p.o box is who
knows where she actually lives
she lives in lake worth
royce royce caved really fast
i will not die on that hill i am not
dying on that hill
oh [ __ ] man or maybe it's like maybe she
lives in like
lantana
by the way this show is becoming this
show is just becoming
60 obscure florida references yes that's
a good point i love it i think it's my
favorite part of the show
but it's fun now because everything is
we make the news a lot and now every
time something bad happens in florida
you guys have like perspective
you know after you're like oh yeah
that's the place you guys always talk
about where the flanigans is
by the highway